au palais royal à paris il y à la
comédie française
il y a les colonnes de buren et le
conseil constitutionnel a cherché
ouverte
mais au juste ces quads le conseil
constitutionnel aura là une bonne caisse
le conseil constitutionnel siège dans
l'est l'ouest du palais royal depuis
le président de gaulle avait annoncé sa
création en même temps que la
constitution de la vème république
le conseil sera la plus haute instance
de l'est sa mission
elle est simple protéger garantir les
libertés fondamentales et les droits
citoyens
pour cela le conseil compte sur neuf
membres nommés pour neuf ans appelée des
sages mais encore neuf sages renouvelé
au tiers tous les trois ans par trois
personnages d'état le président de la
république le président de l'assemblée
nationale et le président du sénat je
jure tous les neuf sont tenus à un
devoir de réserve et de neutralité
une fois que vous êtes nommé vous la
porterez plus à personne et aucun clan
réunis en conseil ils agissent sur
plusieurs plans les élections nationales
d'abord c'est lui qui valide les
candidats leurs parrainages leurs
comptes de campagne et bien sûr les
résultats nos félicitations et nos voeux
les plus chaleureux pour un heureux 70
il agit aussi sur les lois après passage
par l'assemblée et le sénat
si le conseil est saisi il vérifie que
les projets débattus sont conformes à la
constitution
la charge est ouverte si la loi est
jugée conforme à la constitution
elle est définitivement adopté sinon
elle est rejetée pour toujours on dit
alors qu'elle est censuré depuis 2010 le
conseil constitutionnel à une nouvelle
tâche
la qpc la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité en clair lors d'un
procès un citoyen peut demander si la
loi qui le visent portent atteinte à ses
libertés
si elle est conforme à la constitution
alors ça c'est super c'est super même si
ça a considérablement augmenté leur
charge de travail depuis la qpc le
volume de décision du conseil
constitutionnel a été multiplié par 15
[Musique]